bienvenue dans cette vidéo sur le
monopole avec comme références
bibliographiques toujours le show man 2
qu'est ce qu'un monopole cette question
peut paraître étrange tant la réponse
semble en général évidente on parle de
monopole lorsqu'il n'ya qu'une seule
entreprise sur le marché et que le
produit offert par cette entreprise n'a
pas de substituts proches en effet
l'élément central pour le monopole
réside dans le pouvoir de marché dont il
dispose le pouvoir de marché dépend de
l'existence de produits substituts by
poste la poste belge possède un monopole
sur la distribution du courrier c'est
une évidence mais cette activité est
aujourd'hui en concurrence avec d'autres
modes de communication tels que les
téléphones ou toute l'énergie ils sont
permises par internet
ainsi il n'est pas toujours aisé de
décider si on pratique un secteur
particulier doit être considéré comme un
monopole ou non d'une certaine manière
ces frontières sont arbitraires elle
dépend notamment de la manière dont ce
secteur la définit par exemple une
entreprise de textile peut-être en
position de monopole sur certains
modèles de vêtements mais elle n'a pas
le monopole sur les vêtements en général
de manière similaire une entreprise
pharmaceutique peut avoir un monopole
sur la vente d'un médicament particulier
mais il est possible que d'autres
traitements existent pour la même
pathologie
pour illustrer la difficulté de cerner
précisément une situation de monopole en
pratique vous pouvez
parmi les exemples qui vous sont donnés
ici à l'écran distribus distinguer les
sociétés qui correspondent à des
situations d'un marché monopolistique
vous avez ici le château du milord
restaurant deux étoiles du pays des
collines
vous avez la société des chemins de fer
belges sncb
vous avez
le guinness book des records vous avez
le service de livraison à domicile de
fleurs coupées interflora et vous avez
la télévision locale de la wallonie
picarde noter les qu'une entreprise
puisse maintenir sa position de monopole
des barrières sont nécessaires pour
empêcher l'entrée de concurrents
ces barrières explique également les
oligopoles mais dans le cas des
monopoles
elles sont totalement hermétique aucune
nouvelle entreprise ne peut pénétrer sur
ce marché ces barrières peuvent prendre
différentes formes ce peut être des
économies d'échelle également profiter
d'un réseau de consommateurs un peu
comme ebay ebay a une large une large
audience auprès de ses différents
consommateurs
donc il est difficile pour un
consommateur de choisir un autre
concurrent à concurrents d'idées parce
que il sait qu'il ne trouvera pas la
même audience et le même réseau présence
chez ce monopole historique
il y aura également des économies de
variétés c'est à dire que vous allez
pouvoir entendre monopoleurs diversifier
vos activités tandis que de petites
sociétés ne peuvent pas le faire
exemple si vous êtes une entreprise
pharmaceutique qui vont des médicaments
vous pouvez instruments avoir une chaîne
de production cosmétiques
de même la société 3m est active sur
plusieurs plusieurs segments et pas
uniquement sur le segment où l'heure où
la connaît le plus c'est-à-dire les post
it
elle est aussi active dans des réseaux
de pointe comme dans le domaine
hospitalier
on va également avoir différenciation de
produits et une fidélité à une marque
c'est à dire que si vous étiez le
premier la première société à développer
un produit vous aviez forcément un
monopole à la base un monopole
historique et donc avec le temps cette
cette aura va perdurer et c est ce qu on
peut constater avec toutes les marques
qui sont ici proposés à l'écran
généralement n'y pas un marché un
mouchoir jetable on dit un kleenex je
vais à nespresso
je verrai ce que tu n'as pas de tipp-ex
et non pas du tout
aux correcteurs les barrières d'entrée
c'est aussi des coûts inférieurs
évidemment comme la société qui est un
monopole a l'exclusivité du marché
elle a une quantité de produits assez
importante et peut bénéficier de coûts
inférieure au précédent ni soeur elle
contrôle également les facteurs de
production clé puisque auprès de ses
fournisseurs et pas pouvoir vraiment
négocier dans la zone des réductions de
prix ou des conditions favorables pour
l'achat de nouvelles machines
imaginons elle contrôle également les
réseaux de distribution puisque c'est
elle qui fait un petit peu la pluie le
beau temps et du joueur un peu retiré
éventuellement le produit des rayons
dans un certains magasins certains biens
de certaines chaînes de magasins par
exemple et enfin le monopole dans
certains cas surtout quand il s'agit de
monopole d'état profitent d'une
législation favorable qui empêchent
l'arrivée de nouveaux concurrents
on pourrait également parler des fusions
et acquisitions d'entreprises en
situation de monopole peut menacer de
racheter les nouveaux entrants les
dissuadant ainsi d'entrer sur le marché
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on va constater
aussi dans les oligopoles et enfin le
monopoleurs pourra avoir des stratégies
agressif et une entreprise en situation
de monopole sur un marché est vrai
assemblement capable de supporter des
pertes pendant un temps plus long qu'un
entrants potentiels donc le monopoleurs
personnellement casser les prix pour
éviter l'apparition de concurrents le
monopolaire peut ainsi lancer une guerre
des prix et des marais ou démarrer une
importante campagne publicitaire offrir
des services complémentaires attractif
pour dissuader l'entrée de nouveaux
concurrents au point de vue de l'intérêt
général quels sont les avantages et les
inconvénients du monopole les avantages
c'est principalement les économies
d'échelle dont on a déjà parlé mais
aussi une capacité supérieure
d'investissements tant en qualité qu'en
quantité
de par sa taille le monopoleurs peut
vraiment décidé d'avoir des stratégies
d'avenir innovantes et aussi les
développer à très grande échelle au
niveau des inconvénients
c'est évidemment les prix élevés et la
production
moins élevé puisque le monopoleurs en
situation idéale avec un pouvoir de
marché totale peut décider de pratiquer
des prix très élevés et donc là ça fait
vraiment détriment des consommateurs
mais au point de vue d'une efficacité
économique plus générale le monopoleurs
ne veut pas être tenté de produire un
certainement plus qu'il n'en faut étant
donné qu'une production supplémentaire
ferait baisser le prix donc il va
maintenir une production relativement
restreinte pour garantir justement ces
prix élevés le monopôle heures comme il
ne doit pas faire face à une concurrence
acharnée va un petit peu se reposer sur
ses lauriers
c'est ses lauriers pardon et ne va pas
mettre en place de stratégies de
réduction de coûts donc il ne va pas
essayer de revoir ses processus de
production parce qu'il n'en a pas
l'utilité
tandis que dans une situation de
concurrence évidemment vous essayez
toujours de produire le plus moins cher
possible
enfin l'inconvénient du monopole et
c'est aussi une distribution inéquitable
des revenus puisque instamment que se
dire pourquoi est ce qu'une société à la
maîtrise d'un marché et que d'autres en
sont rejetés donc là il ya vraiment une
question là de justice qui se pose est
bien nous voici arrivés à la fin de
cette vidéo j'espère que les notes que
vous avez prises sont complètes
puisque nous utiliserons toute cette
matière dans le cadre du prochain coup
si vous avez d'autres questions ou des
questions qui n'ont pas été abordés par
cette vidéo des choses qui n'étaient pas
claires pour nous nos télés et poser les
au prochain coup your c'est l'occasion
ensemble de faire le point sur cette
matière
et n'oubliez pas évidemment le petit
contrôle qui suit cette vidéo sur son
logis je reste à votre disposition bien
entendu et je vous souhaite un bon
travail une bonne fin de journée et à
très bientôt
le temps